Who are you
Hello Hello everyone welcome this video
tutorial and Normalization in DBMS Vaseline Normalization
of three fundamentally important
concepts back management in
this very crucial for any developer
audit officer administrative tools on this topic sniff
and this topic
first will start with
normalization and understand  What is the
different types of
switch off first second third form and
subscribe normal
david
normalization in dbms
tomorrow morning normalization three us post
explain why im research and this code
hindi 1972 spinner debris flows from to
retail store in different vehicles and
attempted possibility  After Dependency Been
Presented
Normalization Inch Eliminated From Data
Entry Jobs Data Integrity Using Some
Relaxation Techniques In Spirit Launched Into Smaller
Temples And Defined
Relationships Between The Ambulance
Security Organizing Tita Stars And
Imam Zainul Is Like Insert Update Delete
Animals In Certain Normally ESTE Value
Channel Not Been  Sorted in Column Voice
Record About It Can Not Be Inserted
into the Table with the Information About It
You Can Interact with Water at the
Correct Time to Time and
Quit Normally South Africa Generates
Inconsistency Acid Deleted from More Than
One as We Do Not Understand Normalization as Its
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS THAT
THIS PERSON DID
DEATH AND COMBINATION OF DELHI DISTRICT COORDINATOR BAL Multiple Columns
Very Important Part Plus Model in
Multiple Tables for Storing Water and
Stir Well Known to
Retrieve Any Specific
Conditions But What is the President And
Subscribe to
Channel
Subscribe to and
subscribe force ore lumps leg t-20 remember
student roll number or restaurant name
president belongs to such person was
department with student belongs to morning
triple it column is primary that Bigg
Boss has g roll number is primary that
Bigg Boss specific volume  From Which You Can
Identify Individual Record For
Any For Students And You Can See
Department ID School With Foreign Key List Forever Alone But For
Increase In File
That Electrolyte Different Types Of
Was Requested
2014 This Primary Key Point's Description Of Super PM
Candidate Yagnik  This
video is sure about the validity of composite alternate that
this school let's understand what is a
primary that primary that
of which one and more features and
columns of tablet uniquely identify
recording deductible and not accept null
or duplicate values
OK Suryavanshi this 2004 status student
table and  Second 150 Department Table
Spoon Student Table This Column Satyarthi
Student ID This The Roll Number Column Student
Name City Health Department Aaye Tourist
Belongs To So In This Case
Primary That I Will Be Student ID Because You Can See All
So Values ​​Are Unique And Run
Or Repetitions  Gharno
Quote Values ​​for Every Problem Will Also
Considered in Roll Number STD Primary as
Bigg Boss Neither College or School Roll Number for
Each Student Electronic Swiss Roll Roll
Number Roll Unique But You Cannot Have a
Student
and Department's Students with the Same
Name Similarly the Candidates
Belonging to the city and
subscribe
's
lead role number not found department
department had come that a that
promoting world
is next Bihar for their soup and
accessibility billionaire primary's other
table Surya very limited force Saifi solved previous
slide suitable Tubelight
department force student table  Department
ID History for their Virus in
Department Department ID to Primary
that Swayam Means Coast Department ID Column
Indestructible Shruti Primary's
Department is exactly Hindi Department
Table
and Right Subha Hain Behave Super Key Super
Kings of One or More Than One Key Can Be
Used To  Identify You Removed Table
Subscribe
Identification of Students End Right
Side
Subscribe
Indian Student Name Can Be
Similarly Rule Number In Student Can Be Ki
Haddi Student End Finally Bigg Boss
Department It Can Be
Mission School
Ki Naav Movie Do Learning Notice of Candidate
Which Candidate Ki  Team Minimal Super Rate Can
Identify This Record Unilever Table Each Candidate
That They Can Works Primary's
100th Hearty Evening Temple Game Hair and
Party List of Candidates Which Just Mixture
20 Candidates Morning Hotspot of the
Super Which
Candidate Is Also Known  Jab
Minimum Super Ki A
Ajay Ko Ki
Noida Basic Knowledge About Different Ki
Winner Database Let's Look At The Next
Topic Aa Hi Types Of Normal Form Show This
Which First Normal Form Second Normal Form
Third Normal Form And Be Seen After Boys Chord
Normal Form Begun To  Discuss in this
session
Few comments So Planning Hotels First
Normal Form Validation in First Normal
Form with Due to Continue Composite and
Multivalued Attribute Switch Templates
Also Contain a Single Value Edition Record Next
Unique Tenets Bluetooth of People
Cannot Hold Multiple Values ​​Which Scene
Example Sudhir Vacancy Behavior  Student
Table and Established Not in First Normal
Form Kushwaha Multivalued Attribute
Student Phone Number for Student ID 102
With Students Can See Rate Numbers
Multivalued Attribute
New Can Be Transformed to the First
Normal Form With the Right
Side
Purified Contents Only to Make Values ​​and
Single Unit  Sales Pet's 102 Sam Have In
Two Different Phone Numbers In Two Different Russia
Not Possible For Justice For Normal Form
Because The Self To Make Us Understand What
Is The
Meaning Of The Volume To
Subscribe And
Depend On I Secure Election Depend On Anything Until
Primary  Thank you need to
remove biggest target applied to
multiple roles of festivals and please
channel white tables listen understand what is the
parcel dependency leave proper subset of any candidate's
demand was non love tributes it's called
parcel dependency injection
distance which utensils example secretary and course
Table and A that Temple History Columns Method
Professor ES Long The Course Name and Every
Course Fee Navdeep Ko Switch Off But Not Alone Decide the
Value of Professor ID and the
Course Medium Vriddhi Ko Speed ​​Together with
Professor ID Column Cannot Decide Develop The
Course Name
Course  Fee Column Together Method Course Name Column Connaught Decide
Develop Professor ID Hand
Juicer Course Key Problem Now We Husband
In Job Tribute Acid Did Not Belong
To India The Candidate's Tasty Professor
IT Any Course Name
That Indian Record Speak Volumes Depend
Duration Course Name Of Want  TO KNOW THE COURSE FEE
OF PARTICULAR QUESTION Awadhi Course Name
Course Name Column Here Is Proper Subsidy
Ki Shaadi No Entry Ma Entry Course Fee
Dependent Proper Subsidy Ki Na
Subscription To
Error CEO Professor David Kosche
Ne Candidate Ki Ko Subscribe Now To To To To To
To  To To That
Here And This Force To Stable And
Split Into
2000 Professor To Stable And Course PT
Force Wisdom Professor To Research Temple Has Two
Columns Professor ID And Course Name
Similar And Course Duration Course Name
Swiss Role Unique That Duration Course
Fee For Different  Try Want Him To Know
This Year Has Alleged Tak Us Is Arvind SIM
Professors Par Example Professor
Leaders page-01 Teachers Very Physics And
Chemistry Similar
Professor 2003 Teachers Low End Politics
And Professor 202 Teachers Economics And
Statistics And Drop Multiple
Professors Point Pure Only Exam
Point of View
To and Fro
Phase
Professional Life Quest for Ayodhya
Prasad Simple Example of Physics and
Chemistry Refill Hans Similarly for
Economics and Statistics Kospi Aadat Seam To Shades Know the
Second Normal Form Price to Decrease Thee
Ancessory Data Cutting Storage Memory Par
Example Udhar Tan Professor  stitching wash
chemistry switch on two stories pace
504 folder tank watch instant just once
difference to return on 31st chair ok
mysteries of thousand dollars in this also want
to the next normal form this is the third
normal form vowel relationship to be in the
third normal form  Form Definition Second
Normal Form Interest Frustrated Trend Staff
Will Dependency
History In This Also Used To
Easily Creation And Dissolution Of Let's Understand What
Is Transitive
Functional Dependency
With Example Self Transitive Functional
Dependency Access Of Document Dependent On Any Other
Column Apart From The Key
Column In  The Temple
90 Withdrawal Employee Table And
Indestructible Bihar The Employee ID
STD Primary Key All Sadhi Candidate Key Dead
Table Spoon Employee ID And Drop You
Functional Dependency For Example The
Employee Fuel Employee ID Similarly
Department Ne Modi Employers Depend On
This Employee ID Column Behave Differently
City  Depending on the employee ID caller but
the city zip code or the city pin code differs
on the
price city name for example if you want to know this
code of a particular
place you need to know the name of the place where
the city is located
And Employ Citizen Forum Difference in
the City Development Research
Attractive Functional Dependency
Two Two Two Two
Two
You Can See The Original Original Into
Two Table With
Details Hide Details Which
Department Named Man
of the
Match David Willey That
Duration of Primary Candidate's Hair
Serum co lead similar in this table will have only one primary key
special guest zip
code and behave the city forest
officer all right
cancer put non key column sir fully
functional different and only on this primary key column
ki naav meeting hai friends the next
Normal Form With This Theme For A Scotch
Normal Form
Soen Is Chord Normal Foam And Bca This
Special Class Third Normal Form Relation In The
Family Of Every Determinants Of
Candidate's Sorry For Every Functional
Dependency
X Determines Same Edison Always Page's
Horoscope Day Relationship Imagine The  CM of
Up Ki
Naav Lakshya Example Surya Vihar Employ
Table with Columns Employ a Country Which
Team Per Belongs to the Different
Departments This Department Type Hindi
Department Number of People Who Want to Know
Difference Weather to
Employ Them in This Country But I Know
You Can  C Functional Dependency
So Every Country It Should Be
Dependent Upon IT Department Department Department
Department Numbers of the
Department Department Department Candidate
Key
Transfer of Temple 2 Boy This is Normal
for OBC Channel This to break down into the
details you can see why don't you and e
30  Festival This For Employee ID Tasty
Candidate Duration Super Ki Aadhi Aadhi Country Through Your Country
Depends On The Employee ID Similarly In Table Titu Titu
Department Type Column And Department
Number Column Se Depend Ulti On This
Department Column And Hindi
31st Three You Department Is Different On This
Employers IT Share Candidate Keys For
Temples Page For 123 R Family
Department And Employment Department
20132 Notice
Wash Features And Left Hand Side Of Beach
Functional Dependency By Morning Candidate And
Super Key A Possible To Win 2009 And
Died In First Odi And This Video
Tutorial Normalization In  DBMS
Amir
Statement First Look At The
Basis Of Normalization In Tourism
Management System And White Widow And What
Is The
Different Types Of That
Primary Whiteness
David
Subscribe Candidate Key To Key
Indiscriminately One Normal
Subscribe To Believe But All The Value Of
Root
Pintu Different Rooms For  Rent
Hotspot's parcel dependency in tha
second normal form and how you can avoid
parcel dependency in
table in the good the third normal form and
spoke about transitive functional
dependency use this employee table and finally bblnt
baad ab is cord normal
form with example agar agar  Normal
Forms Will Suggest E4 Plus Form Hindi
With Normal Form But In Most Of The Cases
In Reality All The Different Issues And
Normally Ornamental Incessant Devotion Or Update
In This Regard With Thors From All The
Best Uniform Total Thank You For Watching This
Video Tutorial On Normalization  In
DBMS I hope this poses for
interesting 2730 tweet if
people in comment section thanks for watching a
hello hi tube white vinegar subscribe temple
run YouTube channel and WhatsApp on this
standard of inquiry fight for a r o